ya hemos visto que la carga formal es
igual al número de electrones de
valencia en un átomo libre - el número
de electrones de valencia en el átomo
enlazado otra manera de decir eso es que
la carga formal es igual al número de
electrones de valencia que el átomo
supuestamente debería tener menos el
número de electrones de valencia que el
átomo tiene realmente en el dibujo
asignamos una carga formal al oxígeno en
esta molécula recuerda que cada enlace
está hecho de 2 electrones este enlace
de aquí está conformado por dos
electrones
este enlace de aquí está compuesto por
dos electrones y nuestra meta es
encontrar la carga formal en el oxígeno
la carga formal en el oxígeno es igual
al número de electrones de valencia en
el átomo libre el número de electrones
de valencia que el oxígeno debería tener
supuestamente sabemos que es 6 el
oxígeno supuestamente tiene 6
electrones de valencia - el número de
electrones que el oxígeno tiene en
realidad de nuestro dibujo y recuerda
que cuando tienes un enlace con dos
electrones le damos uno de los
electrones a un átomo y el otro electrón
al otro de estos dos electrones el
oxígeno se queda con uno de esos
electrones lo mismo pasa con este otro
enlace el oxígeno obtiene uno de esos
electrones y el otro electrón va al
hidrógeno ahora tenemos un total de 6
electrones alrededor de nuestro oxígeno
lo resaltar tenemos 12
56 hay 6 electrones de valencia
alrededor del oxígeno en nuestro dibujo
6 - 6 es igual a 0
así que la carga formal en el oxígeno es
igual a 0
y déjame continuar dibujando este patrón
que acabamos de ver cuando el oxígeno
tiene dos enlaces
y
parís
y 3
de electrones cuando el oxígeno tiene
dos enlaces y dos pares libres de
electrones la carga formal es igual a
cero
y algunas veces los pares libres se
dejan solo por conveniencia podrías
dibujar esto
con tu oxígeno y tu hidrógeno así o
podrías dibujarlo de esta manera y todas
estas son solo diferentes maneras de
representar la misma molécula cierto
dejando afuera pares libres de
electrones ahora veamos otros ejemplos
donde la carga formal del oxígeno es
igual a cero veremos primero la que está
en la izquierda la carga formal es igual
a cero en este oxígeno y podemos ver que
tenemos dos enlaces aquí con el oxígeno
aquí está uno de los enlaces al oxígeno
y aquí está el otro enlace al oxígeno
los pares libres de electrones se
dejaron afuera de este diagrama de
puntos pero ya que sabemos que la carga
formal es cero ya tenemos nuestros dos
enlaces aquí debería de haber dos pares
jib les de electrones en esos oxígenos
puedes ponerlos o no dibujarlos esta vez
los dibujaré tenemos un total de 8
electrones al red
de nuestro oxígeno el oxígeno está
cumpliendo con la regla del octeto aquí
lo resaltar 2 4 6 y 8 a la derecha
tenemos otro ejemplo donde el oxígeno
tiene una carga formal de 0 y este
oxígeno tiene dos enlaces a él aquí está
uno de los enlaces y aquí está el otro
enlace y este oxígeno también debe tener
dos pares libres de electrones y
nuevamente no los dibuje aquí algunas
veces no los dibujo por conveniencia
pero continuaré dibujando los porque
facilita ver que ese oxígeno tiene una
carga formal de cero y un octeto de
electrones alrededor de él déjame
resaltar los 2 4 6
8 estos patrones son importantes y para
el oxígeno dos enlaces y dos pares
libres de electrones nos dan una carga
formal de 0 veamos otro ejemplo de carga
formal en el oxígeno encontremos la
carga formal del oxígeno aquí
empezaremos dibujando los electrones en
nuestros enlaces cada enlace consiste en
dos electrones
así que los dibujaré cuál es la carga
formal en el oxígeno esta vez la carga
formal es igual al número de electrones
de valencia que el oxígeno debería tener
que son 6 - el número de electrones de
valencia que el oxígeno realmente tiene
en nuestro dibujo dividimos nuestros
electrones otra vez el oxígeno se queda
con uno de este enlace y uno de este
enlace
1 t este enlace
así que cuántos electrones están
alrededor del oxígeno ahora son 1 2 3 4
5 6 menos cinco es igual a más 1
parece que el oxígeno ha perdido un
electrón aquí así que el oxígeno tiene
una carga formal de más 1 puedo dibujar
eso nuevamente déjame continuar
dibujando lo por aquí tengo al oxígeno
enlazado a dos hidrógenos el oxígeno
tiene un par libre de electrones y este
oxígeno tiene una carga formal de más 1
y entonces podemos notar otro patrón
aquí aquí el oxígeno tiene tres enlaces
déjame remarcar esos enlaces déjame usar
rojo esta vez aquí hay un enlace dos
enlaces y luego tres enlaces y luego un
par libre de electrones el patrón de 3
la 6
libre
de electrones para el oxígeno te dará
una carga formal de más 1 y nuevamente
es bueno identificar estos patrones
debes de poder hacer los cálculos y
después de hacer suficientes de estos
ejemplos podrás sólo mirarlos y
descubrir cuál es la carga formal veamos
más ejemplos donde el oxígeno tenga una
carga formal de más 1 y no se dibujaron
los pares libres nuevamente por
conveniencia empezaremos con este
ejemplo en la izquierda podemos ver que
el oxígeno con una carga formal de más 1
tiene tres enlaces aquí hay uno aquí hay
dos y este es el 33 enlaces para que el
oxígeno tenga una carga formal de más 1
tiene que también tener un par libre de
electrones en él puedes dibujarlo o no
yo lo dibujaré en el oxígeno
ahora nuestro otro ejemplo aquí en la
derecha
este es el oxígeno con una carga formal
de más 1 ese oxígeno deberá tener 3
enlaces y un par libre aquí están los 3
enlaces aquí hay 1 2 y 3 y nuevamente no
dibuje el par libre de electrones en el
oxígeno pero el par libre está ahí y
continuaré dibujando lo así reconoce
este patrón tres enlaces más un par
libre de electrones en el oxígeno nos da
una carga formal de más 1 pudiste
también haber descifrado cuántos
electrones son necesarios
usemos este ejemplo
déjame volver a dibujarlo aquí
de qué otra manera podemos descifrar
cuántos electrones hay en ese oxígeno
si ese oxígeno tiene una carga formal de
más 1 o podrías decir bien el cálculo de
la carga formal será 6 menos
6 - x es lo que no sabemos pero lo que
sí sabemos es que la carga formal es más
uno déjame solo en marco esto
6 x es igual a más 1
obviamente x debería de ser igual a 5
lo que significa que el oxígeno tendría
5 electrones a su alrededor pensamos en
cuántos electrones vemos ahora alrededor
del oxígeno déjame dibujar algunos
electrones aquí en rojo
este enlace tiene dos electrones y luego
tenemos varios electrones aquí pero
cuántos electrones alrededor del oxígeno
tenemos hasta ahora tendríamos
tendríamos tres sólo estos tres pero
necesitamos cinco lo que significa que
necesitaríamos dos más lo que significa
que necesitamos un par libre de
electrones en el oxígeno
y eso es un poco complicado creo
demasiado complicado para descifrarlo
pero puedes utilizar ese método o puedes
sólo aprender este patrón y
eventualmente tendrás que tener este
patrón lo suficientemente dominado ahora
veamos otro ejemplo para asignar carga
formal al oxígeno nuestra meta es
encontrar la carga formal del oxígeno en
este ejemplo y dibujar los electrones en
este enlace cada enlace cada enlace
representa dos electrones la carga
formal en el oxígeno es igual al número
de electrones de valencia que el oxígeno
debería tener que es 6 - el número de
electrones de valencia que el oxígeno
tiene realmente y en este ejemplo aquí
tomamos uno de estos electrones de este
enlace y cuántos electrones hay en total
alrededor de este oxígeno
1 2 3 4 5 6
así que seis menos siete nos da una
carga formal de menos uno podría dibujar
eso por aquí como dije el oxígeno tiene
tres pares libres de electrones y una
carga formal de menos 1 así que nuestro
patrón esta vez nuestro patrón es un
enlace aquí hay un enlace
y luego tres pares libres de electrones
déjame escribir eso el patrón es uno
en la cee cuando el oxígeno tiene un
enlace y tres pares
libres
de electrones la carga formal es de
menos 1 tal como vimos aquí con el
cálculo puedes no dibujar los electrones
si quieres ahorrar tiempo podríamos solo
decir aquí está el oxígeno con una carga
formal de menos 1 y deberíamos saber que
debe de haber tres pares libres de
electrones en ese oxígeno veamos un
ejemplo más donde me carga formal sea
aquí este oxígeno tiene una carga formal
de menos 1 y podemos ver que ya tiene un
enlace entonces el patrón es un enlace
más tres pares libres de electrones ya
tenemos un enlace para que ese oxígeno
tenga una carga formal de menos 1
necesitamos tres pares libres de
electrones podríamos podríamos dibujar
nuevamente esto
esta es una manera de representar ese
guión y podríamos también representarlo
así
poniendo los tres pares hyves de
electrones en el oxígeno con la carga
formal de menos 1 y repito
familiarizarte con estos patrones